welcome back to new rock stars is gamora
a variant
fugitive being hunted by the tva after
end game
according to loki's timeline logic who
else ain't where they're supposed to be
in this cinematic multiverse
what about that flerkin the goose is
loose this is
rogue theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love
i'm eric boss going rogue with me today
is
the man who puts the ass and the man
in empty
don't deny that you're an ass man i see
the way you look oh man
i am a major ass man dude uh i live
as an ass man i just i'm just an ass in
general just kidding no it's
true but no um major ass man here gotta
love a good posterior
also with us uh writer actor good friend
of the show marina mastro
also an ass man incidentally another ass
man
i'm just making gags now that is thing
we all have in common
uh comedian and host of the mass effect
adventum podcast
matt acevedo hey and i am also known as
america's ass man it's the ass effect
bro
completing that trinity of ass men jokes
matt you start off with a uh
genuine laugh out of me guys we gotta
ask why is gamora because loki director
kate herron confirmed that steve rogers
did create a branch timeline with peggy
carter at the end of adventures end game
and thus would have probably been a
pruning target
i got a whole other video coming out
tomorrow that's going to explain how
that makes sense and if it does and the
cool implications we can draw from that
but it does confirm a suspicion many of
you have asked us about since loki
episode 1
other possible variants in the mcu
specifically gamora remember an avengers
end game her 2014 self traveled with the
um whole thanos crew to the present day
and all of them dusted away but not her
she switched sides
and was last seen walking away while
everyone else took a knee to pay respect
to tony stark that was in a deleted
scene but i consider it canon because
why not that should happen
right so was drax asking the right
question from the beginning
why is gamora is the tva actually
hunting her
and uh beyond gamora what other variants
do you think could still be loose in the
mcu i think the tv is definitely hunting
tomorrow because she's definitely a
loose factor like she's not supposed to
be
in what 2023 now like she's from 2014
and she's in 2023 and so i think that
you know with
he who remains being uh now gone and now
not a factor anymore that the tva could
actually go after this
gamora who is not supposed to be there
because the person who's
who's running the show is no longer
there so i think gabor could be a really
big target for the tva
yeah i think the question that a lot of
us still have after
loki is what exactly are worthy nexus
events that break people into these
branch timelines is it their mere
existence
out of a out of whatever their proper
sinking of a timeline
or is it the fact that their timeline
will inevitably lead to a kang
i'm inclined to believe the latter but
like can we make any arguments of how
gamora's existence in the modern day
might lead to a future scientist
nathaniel richards discovering time
travel i mean just the fact that she has
access to technology that we
don't at that time and that she's no
longer she no longer has any loyalty
to the characters that she used to right
because this person is
a different person she does not give a
she's like
threw up two fingers and bounced right a
cannon right
i have to wonder if like you know the
end game writers and directors say that
like
thanos his team must have uh reverse
engineered
all these pin particles from this one
vial that they got and that's how they
were able to transport uh
an army of thousands of them to the
present right but like so if they did
that
couldn't we argue that maybe that spare
gamora has some pym particle tech
on her and now that is in the present of
whatever a science wizardry that the
black order
constructed that could have led to some
that could have been like what's it
called the skynet claw
of the t-800 that was there that was
that uh
cyberdyne systems used to create skynet
and d2
i mean we just see her leaving the scene
and end game in the final bow we don't
see her leaving the planet yet right so
we could assume that she did go in and
look through the wreckage for those pin
particles
i think gamora is like i think i i think
you're right on the money i think she is
a key
variant that is not supposed to be here
and is causing a plague to the rest of
the timeline
um by also there's like i think this
opens up so many possibilities just to
so
many different characters that could
come back uh you know for example i
think
in the in episode one of loki we saw
what looked like
uh peggy carter right and i think that
because the steve rogers going back i
think peggy carter might you know be
coming back into the mcu in some way as
a variant
uh but and then on the fan version of me
what i really want is like
i want killmonger to come back uh
because i think michael b jordan is so
good and there was a timeline where like
say he does get the throne he is like he
gets like the upbringing that he gets he
does become the black panther i think
that would be really cool to see
matt you bring up a really interesting
uh proposition there because
this is why i'm so excited to watch um
what if right because we know we have
two episodes that touch on this we have
killmonger saving tony stark
and we got t'challa becoming star-lord
both of which present
likelihoods that killmonger could go on
a different path
and it just makes me wonder are there
going to be any of these loose ends that
are later
brought back into live action as uh
because i think the idea of it
this show still opens with the marvel
studios title card jeffrey wright as a
watcher is
considered mcu canon even if each of
these stories are what if elseworld
stories
there's enough possibility that these
loosens might tie in
and we could have a variant killmonger i
want that killmonger from the what if
uh killmonger save tony stark from the
missile to be
like a variant in the mcu by the end of
what if season one because that'd be
great yeah will they let me pay money
i i think so i think marvel will take
your money i think that's that's they'll
take your money before you even know
that you're paying me
can i just say i love the mystery of
what's gonna happen next because it's so
open it's such blue sky right now it's
like what the heck
are they gonna do so i'm just like as a
fan i am
just thrilled at the possibilities and i
get really excited and i love comics and
it's great
i'm sorry dude
like basically a new phase sort of yeah
at the beginning it's the best it's
everything
out i want to ask you guys about this
idea of a possible
rocket variant because we saw in concept
art that
someone at marvel's like hey let's get
rocket in the tva
so even if that didn't happen and loki
that is a character that
like people some artists someone at
marvel wants to explore
that possibility might just be because
it is kind of an adr character that they
just
they don't have to put the actor on set
it makes it easier
but characters like groot like rocket do
we think that there's some other kind of
variants of those that are
bumbling around the mcu i i kind of
think that i
you know it'd be really cool to see
classic versions of rocket
and like you know maybe like the 2008
comic book look where he looks a little
more like
a big old mustachy kind of rocket or
even
you know but it might even be a variant
because i know you know like scotty
young's comics
uh he did like there was like a clone i
might be wrong
exactly on this but i think there was
like a clone rocket that uh
and they had like a really great
conflict like i i definitely think we're
gonna see
more rockets though for sure opportunity
is too good to not
to not do mine's very stupid there has
to be one
where it's just one uh second of a cut
two and it's just bradley cooper
that's the version of it where it's just
like oh that
okay like that's bradley cooper but he
has the cat cgi
like yeah version of bracket it's his
first song
we don't like that bird
i think that there are in terms of
variance of rocket and groot there
probably are
a ton of them that the tva has pruned
throughout the years
just because of how crucial groot
especially
is to the overall story that kang it
seems to want to tell with
this sacred timeline luke because groot
he took down
ego he sort of basically took down
thanos in a way because his arm was part
of the
axe yeah yeah yeah and like you know
adult groot and guardians one helped
save
xandar in uh in that final battle so
groot is a very
huge like figure i feel in the universe
so grew up the very least and also
rocket because rocket was also
instrumental in all those moments as
well
so yeah i can definitely see them
veering off
slightly like taking different choices
like oh what if rocket did like
decided to use a different kind of bomb
to destroy ego or something like that i
mean right now with what if it's almost
kind of a um
overwhelming luxury of possibilities
that we now have because like they can
just animate anything and anybody into
it and say like oh well it's not gonna
come back but i'm
specifically curious to see if we will
see like live-action
approaches to this and i'm curious about
natasha romanov right like we finally
get this black widow movie
yeah uh there was this weird moment in
avengers end game where natasha didn't
know that her father's name was ivan
right uh but like she knew that her
mother was searching for her
but like just didn't know you would
think that she would have been able to
track him down it's just weird that like
red skull knew about her father but she
didn't just one of these loose ends that
the black widow movie did not address
made me think that there still might be
a future of this character
is it possible that scarlett johansson
comes back in the mcu as a variant of
natasha romanov
i mean i hope so she i know like a lot
of people were
sort of upset that black widow did
certain
things and didn't do other things but i
really enjoyed it i super enjoyed it
actually like the whole time i was just
like yeah
so it's so fun it was it's just like
it's
fine
so i was just like screaming by myself
but yeah and
also like i want to see what else she's
capable of she was basically
the the most super version of her human
self in that and i and i know there's
other versions
i i want to see other variants where she
maybe she gets powers
or maybe we see her have different
skills like i want to see
her more and also like
the except for except for hakka because
he just
he just shoots let's be honest but like
she's the least
capable again because everybody has
powers but like hawkeye is just gonna
stay
stay stay at the bottom of the list um
i know i know eric has vision at the
bottom of the list always but not
anymore not after one division
oh okay i love it vision's always been
my number one boy he's just a nice boy
really number one empty
come on okay steve rogers was my number
one but like vision's just so nice he's
a kind
man i've always yeah he's not a man he's
a robot
man okay synthesized
do you guys think that peter will be a
ver have variance
uh and uh no way home do you think he's
gonna have like
those are gonna be very like the the
rumors of andrew garfield and uh
toby mcguire those are going to be
variants or something yeah i mean if
they bring in
uh alternate peter parker's i believe
variant
will probably be the word they use for
it yeah yeah now yeah look he's kind of
given us the
the lexicon of that yeah this is such a
luxury like
they just wallow in all the
possibilities
we also have um aaron taylor johnson of
course coming up as
um yeah that's a good argument is uh
ralph boner of variant
of quicksilver no he is i could yeah
variant of quicksilver i think that's
what they were setting up in one
division
because we don't know that guy's real
name right ralph boner was his name in
the hex that hex was still up at that
point right so all of them had different
names outside of the hecks
that would have been weird if his name
was pietro maximoff
just saying there's questions there's
questions
no yeah i think there's all kinds of
possibilities there specifically
uh we know captain rogers right
we're gonna explore variants of him if
chris evans comes back in the mcu
i just think the question will be which
of these will be
uh just limited to what if uh which of
these will be hypotheticals that stay in
our head cannon
and which we'll actually see uh yeah and
i
i they have such a ripe opportunity here
to bring in people who are
variants of each other say that someone
is ovarian to someone else like i would
love to see
the fantastic four established as like a
historical group of superheroes in the
60s of the mcu
who maybe died off or disappeared and
then the ones we get in the mcu are
variants from another time cool
fun because otherwise you don't really
get to explore their history i don't
want the fantastic board of an origin
story in the modern day
i want them to have existed because they
are a fun retro
goofy group of people yeah who you know
turn invisible stretch around light on
fire
you know so i i've never seen them in
the 60s yeah
well let us know in the comments below
which character you think might be a
variant or
should be turned into a variant and what
are the variants of characters that we
might see in the mcu
uh but for this conversation matt i
gotta give you the point for the
killmonger
hey thank you thank you very much matt
he's crushing it
he's getting them rogue bucks he's
getting them these guys all
over it i'm excited to catch these in
for the rewards at the end of the
year well we've got some more
questions that we need answers to about
the tva but uh first this is the last
week to grab yourself some loki inspired
merch over at newrockstarsmerch.com
several sizes and styles have already
sold out
mt grabbed one of them so you got to
grab the rest
uh they're going to be disappearing soon
like they got sent to the void at the
end of time
it was the void at the end of time yeah
the void was
right adjacent to the end of time i
don't understand the ultimate
geography of that the waiting room of
the end of time
now go grab yourself some latest
obsession shirts a loki gator sticker
or a mobius on a jet ski shirt so you're
so
support for new rockstars at new
rockstarspurch.com
that's great i'm sold i'm gonna
while you're at it we got some other
people who we would appreciate if you
uh supported financially thanks to
hawthorne
for sponsoring this episode it can be a
little too easy to drop your personal
care routines but
with your personalized grooming kit from
hawthorne
it's even easier to stay on track
hawthorne is a premium grooming brand
that tailors your personal care routine
to your unique profile
first you take their quiz they ask me
things like if i have dry
normal or sensitive skin uh and i said
that's none of your goddamn business
but they said no we're trying to help
you and i said oh thank you i'm sorry i
got so defensive about it sure i have
dry skin
it gives me all kinds of conditions and
grumpiness
and i respond that way to quizzes
sometimes they say we understand we're
gonna take care of you
uh they also asked whether i get
puffiness under my eyes i said do you
watch new rockstars videos or just
listen to our podcast
because i think you'd have to answer
that question uh well it was super
easy and they made me think about other
stuff i don't often contemplate
um you know about life uh and
about whether i really actually care
about myself if i let myself
look the way i look somebody eric no
eric
no in a good way in a good way i'm not
talking about that los angeles
superficiality where
we care way too much about how we look
i'm talking about holistic
approaches like putting on pants when
you take the dog out to pee
it's not just a crime it is a
moral crime to let yourself go like that
so i guess my ideal body wash
would be exfoliating thanks for asking i
could have just cut right to the chase
there but i went somewhere
thanks to hawthorne i got an essentials
bundle with all the products tailored to
my body type and lifestyle i got some
great smelling cologne
some body wash i really like i've got
some compliments on how i smell
hawthorne gives you free shipping on
your order and returns
and uh with their subscription options
hawthorne makes you
never run out of your essentials life is
complicated
obviously hawthorne keeps it simple with
a short study-backed quiz that matches
you with your perfect grooming kit
looking your best has never been easier
take hawthord's quiz today and get
started on your personalized self-care
routine by going to hawthorne.co
and using promo code rogue to get 10 off
your first purchase
that's hawthorne h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o no m promo code
rogue hawthorne.co promo code rogue all
right
also thanks to upstart for sponsoring
this episode look if you're carrying a
credit balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never-ending
cycle of debt like when lady stef kept
kneeing loki in the groin in a time loop
that's how your bank account feels
can help you make that final payment so
you can get ahead
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment and those half a
million people
they're the best people in the world
i'm starting to never committed a crime
none of them
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score and it's expanding access
to affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
because you're more than just a credit
score
well with a five minute online rate
check you could see your rate up front
for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan because i need i
know you need your money fast
one business day guys bam bam thank you
man
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue that's upstart.com rogue
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
rogue and thank you to expressvpn for
sponsoring us
we all like privacy we all need privacy
it's not spelled out in the constitution
but it is a fundamental right
but we all deserve some privacy while
we're surfing the internet
isps like comcast or verizon they know
every single website you visit they talk
about it they judge you
they write it down in their little slam
books about you
and they can sell that information to ad
companies and the tech giants
who then use your data to target you
with what
i don't even want to get into that bad
stuff those creepy hyper targeted ads
for the product you
googled or just talked about out loud
with your friends not really it's just
you're the type of person
there's a whole algorithm lots of
algorithms that are keeping
information about you either way it's
just the tip of the iceberg of that
stuff
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device
and the internet a tube secret so people
cannot peep in on you and your online
activity not saying that you should be
ashamed of it but
you know we do shameful stuff and no one
needs to know about it
[Laughter]
expressvpn is rated number one by cnet
wired and the verge
it works on your phones on your laptops
even your routers i don't know how that
works
i thought router was just like a water
filter
uh but i don't understand technology and
it works on your routers trust me
so everyone who shares your wi-fi into
your home could be protected all the
perverts you're inviting over for game
night
are get it off scot-free
i just love how easy expressvpn is to
use folks you just fire up the
app you click one button and i'm all set
and i like the things that are too
simple for me to mess up you know
because i mess up everything in my
i just i'm a failure just stumbling from
one catastrophe to the next time between
disasters as i like to say
to my therapist who says you're between
therapists now too
it's just not something that takes too
much time
expressvpn interactive thought on a
daily basis which is perfect for me so
secure your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
roguetoday that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash rogue and you can get an
extra three months for
free baby expressvpn.com
rogue you're gonna need those extra
three months you're gonna thank me for
those extra three months you got for
free
jump on this deal keep the lights on
here at new rock stars because
soon i'm gonna be fired how are you
gonna get that extra billion views on
your breakdowns then do
huh huh you need my insanity you need it
anyway eric's having a breakdown so it's
time to go
the ball to the other side of the court
you guys
those are three excellent
oh i don't mean to be angry i'm sorry
insanity sounds like anger to me but
really it's joy it's great and we're all
afraid we're all just
it's a b polar at the controls not lewis
black
but they sound like each other because
they started doing impressions of each
other and they
forgot how to turn off that switch
they're always doing bits down there
um well the tba guys
big big old grain of salt here right but
we here at new rockstars have our
sources too we like to pretend like
we're scoopers
we just have friends who think that
they're more in
access of the studios than they really
are and they pass things on to us and i
say
oh this must be what all the scoopers
are doing they just have a friend who's
a freaking pa
at marvel development and thought they
heard something in the break room
and then now they're a source and a
stupid conspiracy theory that i get
tweeted at 12 times a day
anyway we got one of those too and our
deep throat told us
something gross that i'm not going to
repeat but then he also told us
hey the tva might show up again
in the marvel cinematic universe before
loki's season two
and we said no one's going to believe us
we've made it our whole message not to
spread this stupid that's
unconfirmed
and then we thought well we need a
second topic for rooney
well we need content
for blue screen videos because you know
and then i thought
no one sticks around to the second half
of rogue theory anyway so we can say
whatever we want back here uh but i want
us to kind of crazily speculate on where
do you think the tva will appear next in
the mcu
that's not loki's season two you know
how
the cor there is a court system in the
tva right so if you commit a crime you
get tried it's
it's a kangaroo court you know there's
not much you're going to get sentenced
there's
it's not very fair so however now that
he who remains
is no longer in the picture maybe the
tva's
court system is going to change and
they're actually going to have to
function like a real
court so who is a
superhero and also a lawyer
detective stapler seahawk she-hulk yeah
well and also daredevil but oh yeah okay
for right now forget about him um but so
yeah
so what if um you know in the process of
like
maybe people are going out and being
pruned maybe they're coming they're
being dragged back to the tva
and so superheroes could be coming to
she-hulk
and going like i not only need someone
who understands super stuff but i need a
lawyer like a straight-up lawyer
for time court to represent me and i
think it would be super
funny if and also just like interesting
and also just
she is a good lawyer like she does good
work
yeah so she can she can be
green or gray or whatever and she's
still being a lawyer would i think it
would just be really great
even if it's just like a one-off like
little funny
clip but you could really put it in
almost any show because you could put
anybody who's being dragged into the tva
she could show up to be helping them or
in her series
someone could just pop in and be like
i'm getting taken away by the tv and you
need to have that and then
i love that idea of turning the mcu
on to a legal axis
that's fascinating the tva does not uh
abide by
any uh english common law principles uh
loki did not have a defense attorney
representing him
he didn't wave his right to a defense
attorney they don't have
freaking habeas well i guess they have
habeas corpus if they put him in on
trial you know there they didn't do it
without him
with him in abstentia but like imagine a
scopes monkey trial debate like that
clarence darrow
versus um william jennings bryant who
like
talked about evolution what if they had
like a great debate between the cda
between the tva's best orator and uh and
well the timekeepers are gone there's
nobody to say how the courts should run
now so you know why not like maybe they
just argue their way into getting
defendants now and they're like well
there's no
timekeepers to tell us we can't okay
yeah i guess let's do it
no there's actually precedent for this
in the comics because in the issue that
um introduces the red cannon
to the comics it's it's she-hulk um on
doing time court stuff so like we can
actually do that so like that's a really
good
theory i like that idea all right but
where else where else could uh tba time
door suddenly open up when we didn't
expect it to
i think the next phase of the marvel
cinematic universe is our main the
sacred timeline
royally screwing everything up and
because i gotta put my producer hat on
because
i not not everyone has seen loki and
loki is a key part
of the next uh phase of marvel right um
uh and because not everyone has seen it
you still have to present it in a
digestible way for for normal audiences
so
i think they gotta go through the with
the thanos approach and we're gonna get
post credit scenes are gonna be some
sort of tva thing
it's gonna be a little little yummy
we're gonna build it up we're gonna gain
uh get get the every other the people
who don't watch
are the hardcore fans like us on board
so that they can be like oh this is just
like that thanos kind of thing and build
our way up to them so i think it's going
to be the next series it does mess with
the timeline
every postcard almost every post credit
scene is going to deal with the tva
maybe heavily more uh with ant-man uh
three
uh since we're dealing directly with
kang um apparently
so i think it's to be building to that
and kings we're going to have a a
heavier presence
with the tva but up top so you think we
got shanxi coming up in a month
you think we're going to have a
post-credits scene with the tva there
i do i do that's the way to get them get
them on board
you know leave the little trails get
caught up with us you know i disagree
that i
i do think more people have watched loki
than most of these other marvel shows
but you are right not everyone's a
disney plus subscriber i know because i
have dumbasses who are like how are you
spoiling black
widow it's like two weeks clearly you
don't consider it worth your time or
money
so you don't have the right to complain
to me about spoilers about it you
support the
thing and then you know whatever well
also don't follow you if you don't want
spoilers like yeah exactly
you know no one's allowed to complain
about spoilers anymore i'm sorry no i'm
sorry there was some
idiot writer for av club at some point
who uh
listened to the studios uh uh i have a
theory that spoilers are a form
of oppression
it is gatekeepers and comics who believe
that there is one way to fan
yeah and on the opening hours they say
oh you want to watch to talk about this
right away shut up don't talk about
until i have seen it
that is a form of gatekeeping so no
spoil everything and then just don't go
on twitter if you're worried about
spoilers yeah also like just
this is just like my philosophy for life
and it's pretty great you know the
journey is the destination y'all it's
cheesy as hell but it's true man
what the hell does that mean matt that
doesn't apply to what we're talking
about you can trap in here with your
chicken soup for the soul
and trying to tie it together what do
you think fortune cookies man
a little youngs oh spoilers whatever man
how do we get there that's important
i love how me and mt immediately
supported matt and then eric was like
[Laughter]
we were like yeah
you are right though i think we're going
to start seeing some uh it's kind of
like how we had scroll post credit
scenes like another scroll post credit
scene one division they're gonna do that
with the tva too i think
yeah oh yeah i think that you know with
especially again with shanghi i think we
might actually
see the tv pop up during the course of
wenwu's super long life because when was
a very
long-lived person i feel um it seems
through the uh the flashbacks
so yeah if if he's been around for a
while they might be like hey
uh what are you doing here like why
you're not supposed to be doing this and
he just
fights them off with the ten rings and
they just run away because like wow we
decided
but no either that or the eternals
because the eternals yeah
uh you know let's just do this this way
turtles instead of that way it's like
okay we got you because like they're
they work on behalf of a cosmic being so
maybe the eternals know
that the tva exists i don't know yeah
the more i think about it like there's
starting to be these little mental links
that i'm forming like
not only is he remains or someone some
kang is obsessed with
ancient wonders of the world like we
have two of them in the void we're gonna
get a third one in eternal so the
hanging gardens of babylon
and the fact that there's this sphinx in
the void and
like kang one of his forums is pharaoh
rama tut
and i think we'll be visiting ancient
egypt in the eternals
uh that the eternals have all this
random crap they have like
don't they have the not the ark of the
covenant they have the holy grail
oh they have like random stuff in their
treasure box that feels like
something kang would like just there's a
lot of these weird parallels it makes me
think oh maybe we'll
we'll see a time door show up in
eternals i think it's the most likely
out of
most projects well there's quantum mania
but like either quantum mania or
eternals
i feel is the biggest one for the tv
well i think quantomania is a guaranteed
that we're yeah
absolutely and tva elements the only
thing that like leads me to look away
maybe from eternals
in terms of a possible tva connection is
just the tone
of it like right it might break the
tonal reality that chloe zhao
seems to be going for in eternals which
i guess is like
historical
i don't know what that is looks cool
yeah pretty landscapes
um i think you know that's a really good
point because it would sort of break up
what
what chloe jiao is doing but like maybe
a post-credit scene when the movie's
over
it's like yeah that way no one cares
yeah
like that's true but i mean the part is
over now it's time for more marvel set
up you know it's
that's true that is true yeah yeah
i want time doors to show up everywhere
we're having squirrels show up and with
squirrels and time doors i want
squirrels coming in and out of time
doors showing up everywhere
let's mix peanut butter with chocolate
there let's go nuts i want the last
battle with kang to be portals but with
time doors you know
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah like you know
like the scooby-doo like uh
trope where like they just keep running
across the hall to different doors yeah
yeah
oh yeah yeah but time doors
we should have already had that the fact
that we didn't get that loki we should
be in this
writing right now let's see marina i'm
going to give you a point for
uh a uh hulk chief prosecutor
yeah trial
i'm going to give you a point for
bringing up eternals as a likelihood
yeah i do like that idea
very good very nice then uh
i'm going to give you half a golden uh
buck matt
because i like your idea i just i i
wanted you to already have locked and
loaded
uh a post-credit scene ready to go
and and he really threw me with that
chicken soup
whatever that was so i deducted half
i think it's fair though you're still in
the lead you're still probably going to
win all this
because you're on fire today my friend
that's correct
i can't i can't extinguish those flames
as hard as i try
oh no nobody can no no leave him thank
you
oh here we go guys uh rogue questions
time
with disney's jungle cruise film
premiering today
we get another entry into the movies
based off disneyland rides
universe so previous entries of course
include pirates of the caribbean
the haunted mansion and the country
bears so pitch me the next
likely blockbuster film based on any
ride at a disney park
thunder mountain baby it is the next big
and they they explore the pirate genre
they're going to capitalize on the
western genre it's going to be about
some sort of treasure that's located
for at this magical mountain that no
one's found yet called thunder mountain
and it's going to follow some uh uh oh
my gosh who uh tim
what's his name in a mandalorian who
always plays the cowboy he's gonna be
the man
that's right he's gonna be the main
character and he's gonna have a really
fun crew of of
characters are like probably josh gad's
in there it's comic relief you know
like answers and throw emily blunt in
there throw her in there too
you know and she's like she's like a
smart like uh like she's the
archaeologist or whatever and like it's
it's kind of like a western version of
indiana jones but with thunder mountain
as like the
the you know the main thing yeah i love
it
all about it i love the energy
everything about that
opening right there thunder mountain is
so good
i'm gonna choose uh the only disney ride
that i know
uh it's a small world after all uh
it's just you know having about you know
about two yeah what's it about
tell me on the concept maybe it's like a
it's like an ant-man
but a disney man i don't know uh-huh
and like you're on a river i don't know
how that ride is you go
around the world on a river and there's
little dolls from different countries
who sing at you
um mine's a mine's a horror
and a horror movie okay okay and um
it's about the main character is this
woman
and she's so hungry and she's like what
am i gonna do
um i'm so hungry and then she's like
i'm gonna go to this hot dog cart and
she buys this
hot dog and she takes a bite and she's
like wait
i don't know what's in it and then it's
just
disneyland hot dog cart you don't know
what's in it
that's it and josh did it
[Laughter]
i'm sorry guys you all got it wrong the
correct answer is the hall of the
president
imagine a president where all the
presidents were together
it's gonna win it's gonna be like
lincoln it's gonna
look like a kind of way that wins oscars
but then people can be like not this
year
i like that that's based off the ride
not just not off of the president
yeah yeah it's just a ride
no one else is in the room and the
league just gets going
you know what he's talking about uh
pythagoras
now and how all things being equal to
each other are all equal to god
and then adam driver's like i'm in this
movie yeah
and he's like he's like very he's you
know shirtless and
sweaty oh yeah well that goes about
insane it's that
driver right yeah oh yeah that's a given
i would hope so that's how we sell that
that's the end god
of rogue theory this week matt you're
our winner
yeah good job great it's a team effort
we did it guys
no it was all you you did
you alone fixed it good job matt don't
buy it everyone else is trash
yeah we suck thanks man you killed it
buddy
uh but of course uh mt marina you are
also here
i love talking nerdy with all of you
guys it's been a lovely episode
one of my favorites so be sure to follow
all three of these lovely people marina
masters
matt acevedo mt find them on social
media tweet them nice things
show them some love you can support this
channel by checking out
all that merch i talked about earlier at
newarkstarsmerch.com
uh follow me at eavos follow new
rockstars
uh forgive me on twitter i seem
grouchier on twitter than i am
here it's just because here's the secret
folks everyone's grouchier on twitter
than they are in real life or anywhere
else it's not the person's fault it's
twitter's fault
burn down the text social media
companies
but burn the rest of them down yeah
anyway
subscribe here on youtube see you next
time
[Music]
you